the rumors were flying but now the news  is confirmed we're getting two new  Pokemon versions this year Pokemon Sun  and Moon were officially announced  during the latest Nintendo Direct the  games are set to release this holiday  season but no specific date was given we  didn't get to see the game in action  either but we did get a glimpse of some  concept art plus I can pretty much  guarantee you'll still be choosing a  fire water or grass type starter Pokemon  and thanks to red blue and yellow  versions up for sale on the eshop you'll  be able to bring the original 150  Pokemon all the way up to Sun and Moon  those aren't even the only pokemon games  releasing this year pokken tournament  hits wii u march 18 keep it locked at  gamespot for whenever Nintendo teases  more we're so ready to catch them all  all over again